obviously you make a lot of mistakes
that's you know that's just life and you
learn from it
but the best part is just building teams
um i have a saying that you know
the best capital the actually the only
capital is human capital
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeword ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serena partners and in media partnership
with c-tech
welcome to 20-minute leaders meet noam
rabinovic cto and co-founder of eversea
nami's ever sees cto and co-founder
eversea's mission is to reduce online
payment cyber crimes by developing
technology that will enhance the
transparency of the internet
nom has extensive experience in leading
development teams as well as building
technology for sophisticated data mining
algorithms machine learning models and
ai he has recently launched eversea's
newest solution for e-commerce market
view this solution is set to eliminate
hazardous and counterfeit product sales
on marketplaces nom is a tau graduate
with a bsc in computer science and
economics
[Music]
welcome to 20 minute leaders founder and
cto of eversea how are you
i'm great thank you michael for having
me on board i'm super excited
nice to be here thank you for coming
thank you for coming all the way from
new york uh it looks sunny and beautiful
here it's dark and cloudy and so it's a
i feel that i'm i feel in the same room
with you it already makes me feel better
and and i have a feeling we're going to
have a really fun conversation today
about an entrepreneurial journey that is
really unordinary with a lot of
interesting lessons along the way and
nom you founded
ever see almost 13 years ago uh today
you're you're in new york and and you've
had quite a journey with this company
with some incredible people uh raza
brahma one of which was on the show a
while back and i'm and i'm really
excited to get your perspective into you
know this founders journey and and what
you're doing in cyber security world and
and validating market in really unique
ways and so nom tell me a little bit
about yourself and how did you ever even
find yourself in everc
yeah that's uh quite the journey as you
mentioned
and you know just a bit about myself i
grew up in israel um in richon
um
you know uh that
did military service started in an
intelligence unit an uh field
intelligence unit then moved to a
technological
uh division
after that uh tel aviv view for computer
science and economics
um 34 years old recently had a baby
which is a life-changing experience
and have been for the company for just
over a decade as you mentioned
um super you know crazy journey all
along ups and downs and you know
sideways
um early days were so different than
what we are today
where do you want me to start
well take me through you know walk me
through your your sort of your mind and
how your brain works and and and the
maybe the primary experiences that led
to you wanting to even start your own
company
yeah so i grew up you know i grew up
with uh
entrepreneurial parents or you know my
parents have their own businesses which
i guess had its effect on me none of my
parents were
um employees they ran their own business
with all the hardship that it you know
brings in uh my parents to date work
crazy hours even though they're
uh you know into their 60s and
kudos to them and i think i grew up with
that spirit and
i
never even thought of you know getting a
quote unquote a day job
uh i moved in from being you know a
contractor you know code for hire pay me
i'll write the code that you want
uh into building in my own company once
i met you know the right partners and we
partnered up and
um you know quote unquote killed it
i love it i love it okay so
ever see what
what what field are we in even when
we're talking about everything what what
is ever see
what does it mean
yeah so you know when we started the
company it actually um it was called
ever compliant and we had ambitious gold
ambitious goals around um
setting up a generic compliance solution
little did we know at the time that we
were too small and
you know
too naive to actually pull up such a
solution but
you know as as you mentioned the way uh
the way shapes you uh the the way you
travel the way you travel that shapes
you and gets you along the way um
throughout you know we've learned from
our customers and we're able to get
into
different spaces we've always been a b2b
company
um to date we run two major products one
of them is called merchant view one of
them is called market view
neither is e you know per se a complete
like a compliant solution it does
it does give a compliance uh perspective
and it does help with compliance but
it's not the original name ever
compliant um so hence we went with you
know a shorter nicer name ever see we're
playing on the c
uh as in like we see everything versus
like ever compliant
um and we
basically uh put as a goal to illuminate
the darkest corners off the web you know
and find all the bad stuff and help
prevent the bad stuff that happening on
the web mainly focused on
illicit an illegal trade that's
happening on the web and help players
prevent that
sounds very simple
and
i'm joking of course
now most people validate their you know
some of their ideas by you know doing
zoom calls reaching out to customers you
know playing around with getting
surprised you had a quite a unique
experience in the way that you started
validating your idea and actually that
experience shaped a big part of of the
of the remainder of your journey so tell
tell me about atlanta
yeah oh yeah definitely so you know when
we started uh when we started we
operated from a small office it was
about 80 square meters in richmond
luzion just under a pool joint if you
were to work later in that office you
would get quite the experience with you
know some elevator rides with people who
you know went up and down in that from
that pool joint and trust me that's not
the place to like walk around at night
uh too much it was like kind of a you
know industrial area not very
uh
not the best place i don't want to say
anything negative but not the best
greatest of place but it worked for us
at the time
um we had a handful of customers in
israel
um banks to be to be exact
and
they gave us i think the greatest gift
for this company so we were actually
serving them with a product that today
is discontinued as i mentioned had to do
around compliance more specifically pci
compliance super boring i'm not going to
get into that
and one of our client came to us and
told us hey
i have this massive problem you know i
was just fined
for
um facilitating gambling even though for
the life of me i never intended to do so
i don't do that and we basically said
you know what
let us
let us look at that let's look at that
and you know what we saw was amazing we
looked at the entire portfolio and we
found a bunch of players under this bank
that basically opened the counts
falsely declared their intention one of
them you know was a computer service
shop and other did other type of things
each one of them
actually did
bad stuff that the bank did not want
under their books right one of them was
basically a host for adult entertainment
cameras so you could get girls on
cameras the bank never wanted to
facilitate those transactions but they
presented themselves as
a shop um a shop that fixed his computer
the other guy uh you know was running an
online casino which the bank never
really wanted to deal with um and didn't
have the proper license to deal with but
they present the self as like a
convenience store um and put the bank at
harm's away while you know exploiting
the system
and that kind of like was an aha moment
for us
because we then realized
wait it's that easy
like the bank would look at your you
know transaction records and would make
sure you know you don't have any
criminal record or whatever it is that
is legal in your country are you in debt
are you in you know whatever shape or
form you are
will look at your scores all around to
lend you credit but when it comes to
opening a business account and giving
you an acquiring like an acquiring bank
giving you access to the payment system
they would go ahead and just
plain ask you
what is it that you're doing right like
what is what business are you in and if
you michael
let's say
are a bad guy you're probably not gonna
tell the bank
hey dear bank i'm a bad guy and i really
want to do business with you how about
you give me an account no you're just
gonna you know present yourself as an
you know nice low-risk guy to the bank
and say hey i have a pet store
uh you know i want to be able to accept
payments in my pet store
and it shocked us right that's the
extent
of the you know background check and
tools and technology that was available
to the bank so we right away
not right away actually we
um rushed to get in touch with you know
mastercard global mastercard uh and we
wanted to go to mastercard and tell them
hey guys there is kind of like
somewhat of a flaw an inherent flaw in
how the payment system is designed you
don't really know
where the payment is from who does it
belong to that's like
you know like you're
look 10 years back like we're thinking
that we're sitting in regional like
we're we're shocked right we're not sure
what to do so it took us a while to get
into you know to get a meeting with
mastercard and you know us good israelis
we wanted to maximize that trip to the
us
as we planned that trip to the us
carefully we also set up a few other
meetings
as luck would have it the first meeting
was in atlanta with a potential business
partner uh that was supposed to you know
sell our product
as we get out of this meeting
an event of once in a century literally
one once in a hundred years happened
it started snowing in atlanta for those
of you who don't know that really
doesn't open happen that often at least
not until then
hashtag global warming or whatever you
want to call it and we found ourselves
you know
about to go to the airport to catch a
flight back to new york to go to that
all exciting meeting with uh with
mastercard to tell them what we know and
learn and you know try to get pumped um
and then we're like i'm getting a phone
call from american airlines saying sir
your flight's been canceled
and i'm saying
so that like that's it there's no more
flights leaving atlanta it's one of the
biggest airport in in the united states
um
no more flights leaving
what do you do
so you know us israelis nothing going to
stop us open google maps navigate to
mastercard headquarters in new york
and look at the phone and says
roughly give or take 13 hours drive
so
we headed to the airport
went to the car rental
rented a minivan
and the three of us we drove overnight
um in shifts you know like one guy's
driving the other guy is sitting in a
car and one guy sitting in a back
sleeping resting and we you know change
overnight
got to new york in the morning like the
craziest drive drive through a snowstorm
13 hours
getting to new york eyes shut red you
know like your eyes like popping red
washer you know wash our face in a gas
station suit up
and getting to that meeting which
you know by the way it doesn't give you
any credit any any points it's just like
this is how easy it was
um unbelievable and
you know to our pleasant surprise we
walked there with matt you know they
were very polite nobody said oh your
eyes are as red as if you were partying
all night which we haven't um
and then uh you know we talk to them and
we tell them hey guys you know there's
something wrong you know in the way that
the payment system is doing a lot of
people can take advantage they can hide
the true nature of their transaction and
you know to our pleasant surprise was
like
yeah we know what can you do about it
um so at that point
i mean that was like a pivotal point for
the company from there on um they tested
our technology themselves
and it was so urgent that while doing so
they referred us to one of the largest
largest financial institutions in
america to
start working with them just just just
incredible you know and i can only
imagine you know what those 13 hours
must have been like and obviously
arriving in mastercard i mean it's
literally like a it's like a hollywood
movie i can
it's a little similar to like the the
story of the hangover without the the
hangover part of it but but but
definitely like a similar happenstance
along the way now
from that point you're basically growing
everything you're becoming you know more
and more knowledgeable in this domain
and you're developing various solutions
so
talk me through sort of the different
phases of the company
reaching up to now
yeah so the phase i mentioned to you i i
don't know you know don't hold me to it
but roughly just under 10 employees
signing one of the biggest financial
institutions in the us realized okay
we're probably gonna go ahead and raise
some money now to be able to serve such
a
uh you know such an intense and big
enough big opportunity um
we went ahead we found great partners uh
the the our first round was led by at
the time carmel ventures now viola
ventures um great great financial
partners there were some other uh great
partners that join along like nika
partners which um you know is led by
hans morris
for those of you who know him from the
fintech industry great guy formerly uh
president of visa which is someone you
definitely want on your side when you do
what you when you do what we do
um and then from there on you know
climbing through the steps and it's it's
funny you made the joke that it's um
sounds easy um raz and i had raz is my
partner who was on this show and another
techie himself
and
i think halfway through developing this
solution we realized how intense and
hard this technology is so our joke was
like
next startup we're doing something easy
like you look at our you know some of
our friends are doing things that
i bet they have their challenges but it
appears easy from the outside and we
went ahead and we said
we're going to look at banks we're going
to look at their clients and we're going
to tell you which one of their clients
is not who they say they are which is
kind of you know
it's challenging let's call it
challenging yeah um
yeah and it made us took us through a
journey when we had to you know build
crazy operations at the time
uh i think 2014 2015 dealing with uh
technology technological challenges that
were not sold were not off the shelf
like we needed to build our own graph
database solution because nothing off
the shelf could support
um could support that really the scale
that we needed
we had to come up with so many problems
that scale had um that you just it's
the call is not long enough for that
i i can completely see that what did you
enjoy most on your journey until now if
you had to sort of think you know for
yourself nom what what which part really
you know drove your you know passion and
ambition here what was it
i think you know to be fair um over
over this journey and more specifically
over the past two years
um
obviously you make a lot of mistakes
that's you know that's just life and you
learn from it
but the best part is just building teams
um i have a saying that you know
the best capital the actually the only
capital is human capital right that's
all that matters to it
um two years ago we were uh presented
with a new challenge um if our first
solution had to do with players you know
pretending to be someone they're not
we were presented with another yet
another challenge and i could tell you
that during my experience
the best information cam came from
paying customers or from customers that
have a need
and if you're lucky enough to be able to
you know get in front of a customer with
a need and uh you have the right tools
to be able to extract that information
from the customer and you're uh you're
you're able to turn it around
uh we were able to go from a poc into in
early 2019 to a six digit deal
uh in 2020 to a seven
a very high seven digit operation for
our new product
um two year old project two-year-old
sorry two ill product uh with a great
team and
one of the things i enjoy the most
is you know putting together a team and
seeing people who you know just flourish
you know chat
dealing with challenges killing it and
uh making a lot of success in a way
so what are you most more excited about
the compliance piece of things or the
entrepreneurial side of things because
you know we started the conversation
with you know this understanding and
this aha moment that that you know so
almost you drove you know insane with
the opportunity here and what you're
discovering but then i'm hearing the
excitement and the passion of the
entrepreneurial journey along the way
yeah that that you know that for me is
um super exciting uh i'm a big big fan
of challenges
um both you know both technical
technological big data challenges but
also you know on the business side how
do you make how do you make a solution a
solution financially viable right how do
you find a solution financially viable
um our latest product market view that
helps marketplaces and e-commerce
platform
um clear out bad products from their
that product can tell apart you know
illegal drugs from prescription
pharmaceuticals from counterfeit louis
vuitton bags
and how do you make that product you
know financially viable for customers
and you're able to scan so many products
in so long time just to give you an
example you know throughout 2021
we've had
over three billion requests to that
service um way above three billion
requested that service and you operate
on very thin margins and how do you you
know how do you make that you know
business operation work how do you
leverage
um the people you have in your team how
do you leverage their capabilities in
order to create one-of-a-kind solution
and that is super exciting that's like
one of the best experiences you can have
nom
a incredible journey that it sounds like
it's you know we're just in the middle
of it and there's there's ways to go and
incredible stories that you know i think
will will keep you thinking and keep
others thinking and entertain for a long
long time
and i can only put my try to put myself
in your shoes and and and how and how
it's feeling and i'm jealous i want to
have those experiences and so i really
thank you for for sharing them with me
here and spending this time with me i
know how busy you are and and thank you
for you know for the great work that
you're doing for all of us really
humanity and you know we're talking
about impact this is pure impact and
helping you know with a huge ripple
effect and putting the world in order so
thank you and stay safe and stay healthy
nom
thank you michael
[Music]
you